let's say Will and Jay to break up like
Jada leaves who who is the worst who is
the worst heartbreak Willard now now I
would say his will because he's stuck
with a fruit everything that's going on
including him going up to Chris Rock and
just humiliating himself in front of the
whole world Jada isn't really losing
anything like she's built up her
credibility if anything I don't feel
like she's gonna lose anything from
separating with him she might even want
to and this will from the outside
looking it looks like it's real that's
trying to hold on to it and that's
possibly just because they have kids
together but that's just my perspective
on things that's how I look it from the
outside look at it
like and even I just I just look at that
scenario as that protector scenario
situation again let's just look at this
your woman has been disrespected you
might not even you might have been found
that was a violation but you looked at
her and she's not happy now you need to
go and do something and this is that
thing where I talk about as well when I
keep talking about men and women's
protectors but when we say it they want
to act like we're not but when will did
that so many women were like defending
and saying yeah they disrespected Jada
her hair and she's got alopecia and this
and they forget all the other stuff that
Jade has done they were just like yeah
that's what I want my man to do but you
know what he didn't even have a problem
until he looked at her because at first
he laughed at the joke himself and then
he looked uh saw that she was pissed and
then he went over and said you know I
gotta do side now because if I don't
she's gonna come and chat [__] to me in
the bedroom and I don't want to hear
that and as a man we go through that
because you don't want to hear your
woman woman just in your ear talking
rubbish so I feel like he was pressured
into that situation I don't feel like he
doesn't have to off his own back I feel
like he was pressing into that situation
no I fully but I just use it as another
example of just Usman protectors and
what women look for us to do now if you
didn't do that in that scenario look at
like we was laughing and she looked at
him like oh you're gonna laugh and then
he had to get up and he had to go and
become something and look what he threw
and thrown away and look what he threw
away and this is what I keep talking
about women about about scenarios where
men have to step in and do things and we
put ourselves on our career and all of
our things on the line and people
completely disregarded but can I just
say something it's all on that subject I
think that in itself sends out a bad
message to what's happening like with
women these days because she is another
woman who doesn't listen to her man yeah
yeah you see when there's around a red
table talking remember he said something
about old I'll give you my permission
and she was like no you don't give me no
permission so this is the message that a
lot of these girls are getting that you
know you can have a man that's going to
go and risk it all to protect you but
you don't have to listen to him when he
says anything you can do what the hell
you want humiliate him and it's all good
you know but it's not the real world
really isn't it and what does it say
about the like what we're teaching men
do except from women
you ever think like even when like um
like when I hear songs from the early
2000s and it's like I don't know it's
like Bob I'm gonna still sing to it but
yeah but it's like like we have all of
these songs about you know that kind of
[__] on men and I feel like we really
haven't taught men to like value
themselves and think highly of
themselves and say like you don't have
to accept that behavior from well then
that's bad behavior and your woman
shouldn't gain weight when she's with
you and she shouldn't sleep around
before she's met you and you deserve a
pure young wife but we we shame them
when we when they want these things oh
this changes that's why I prescribe man
these hoes ain't loyal that was like
that was one for the boys yeah
so when those scrubs came out as well
that was probably like what maybe 15 20
years ago maybe longer longer yeah cool
so that song came out a long time ago
this like I'd say relationships were a
lot different where men were a lot more
masculine in those times now
like not to say that men are like
b-i-t-c-hs and relationships but we are
like taught to not be as masculine as we
once was like say for example if you
look at these movies that we're watching
these days most guys are
guys that are just tired and they just
get abused by their women in these films
and it's like that's what they want the
role model of a man to be now where the
woman plays the masculine role in
certain relationships whereas before
back in the day the man was like this
much old man that used to go out and do
anything or defend their woman they'll
do anything but now they want their
guy to be Lil Nas for example even the
term toxic masculinity is just it's not
real because there's nothing toxic about
being masculine so even attaching
toxicity to masculine it creates a bad
connotation image in people's mind it's
like saying toxic femininity right
um there's nothing toxic about being
feminine and if you're hyper feminine
that's a good thing so if you're super
masculine why would that be a bad thing
so but when you create a scenario where
where men can't even be what they're
supposed to be naturally see what are
you doing now so you're if a man wants
to be stronger if he wants to go gym if
he wants to be actually you know what I
want to look after my women I'm our
protector all of a sudden now these are
things a lot of things that are
naturally in us and we want to do it but
then when you step out into the world
they're going to tell you no no no no no
and make all these things to be bad and
derogatory and misogynistic but in
reality these are just things that are
naturally in our body so when they start
creating uh movies and stuff where they
show hyper feminine males
um it's just the majority of them these
days you look at all of the films that
are probably released in the last five
to ten years most of the guys I've just
done out here yeah but a lot of times
women support this so you know it is it
is a lot of women support this idea of
of we don't we want feminine men but
then when they get feminine men in real
life when they meet them you know that's
why they hate them yeah they hate them
because they no one like you said you
want a man to defend you want a man to
do certain things so I just think women
have to really ask themselves what do
they want do you want a man that's gonna
he's gonna sit there with you in the in
you know in Starbucks and you're gonna
talk babe tell me about your friend tell
me about your neck You're Gonna Take It
to the nails gonna do your hair all of
these things or do you want a man that's
gonna be like actually babes um here
here's my card go buy that send a
picture of is that what you're wearing
I'll change that
um
um I don't want you to go there but if
you are going to go there then just make
sure you let me know what you're doing
who you're with like these are just
natural things masculine things that men
are gonna do or do you want a man that
doesn't care where you go who you're
with and it's okay when you're coming
back
um he doesn't you know do you it depends
what you consider love is and if you've
never had that before there's nothing
more than one a man is literally trying
to figure out where you are not because
he's worried oh babe I'm gonna come and
pick you up if you're not driving
actually you know what um I'm gonna go
grab your mum because actually auntie
wants to go to church on a Sunday and I
should go these are all masculine things
that we do but if you've never
experienced it it's because the types of
guys you were dealing with the wrong
types of guys and I've already taken
from some of the things that you've said
is that maybe you figured out some guys
that you should have seen before now we
know this you're 28 you have no children
you have you come from a family with a
father figure in there you have your
sister next to you you know I'm trying
to say to you have your head screwed on
go outside and go and get the man that's
going to take you down the aisle and
it's going to have a beautiful life with
you
and protect you
okay I'm gonna take a second to read
Super Chat
um okay guys like the video we have over
2 000 people watching right now so we're
only at 950 likes we should have a
thousand yeah we can we can clap we can
clap
um we should have at least a thousand
five hundred likes I like history it
takes you two seconds to like it so make
sure you like the video
um okay so bro Dion
is there a spectrum of being alpha or
beta certac Pearl as you show every day
Millennial and gen Z Chad Chasers have
created a zombie apocalypse apocalypse
of alpha widows these two generations of
women are lost to history um newbie um
Crypt to be only women children and dogs
are loved unconditionally a man is only
loved under the condition that he
provides as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible